e aí
e eu gosto muito dessa frase mas como
todo bom geminiana tem um monte de
perguntas esse meu dom foi ensinar e for
servir for vender procurar vou fazer rir
vou cuidar tudo ao mesmo tempo como é
que eu me apresento como é que eu subo
aqui falo eu venho aqui me identifico e
eu falo quem eu sou
oi oi eu me revelo e falo quem sou eu né
e 2006/2007 eu te passei por uma
revelação muito boa foi liberado de uma
obrigação eu conversando com o consultor
em recursos humanos e declarado ele
empregável eu pagava aquela pessoa e a
pessoa falou não vou mais tomar o seu
dinheiro você não vai arrumar um emprego
vai ficar mal para mim né foi libertador
porque aí o pude começar a pensar em
juntar o quem eu sou
e com quem sou eu o cpf vai virar um
empreendedor a cnh vira pai leva a
criança para a escola faz as coisas né
tudo que eu tenho de identificação vir a
minha identidade e aí foi um daqueles
momentos em que você aprende vou juntar
o meu objetivo com meu subjetivo eu vou
juntar o meu papel eu vou juntar o meu
cargo com o que eu quero fazer
oi e aí nesse tempo tivemos um momento
just do it vou começar a empreender
vamos começar a quebrar essas barreiras
mas vamos começar a empreender o que vão
empreender um negócio que permita que eu
seja pai cozinheiro palestrante
professor cuidador junto com
empreendedor vamos permitir que seja eu
completo dentro do que eu tô fazendo um
empreendimento que sai desse paradigma
horroroso da escassez que gera
competição que gera exclusão que gera
[Música]
crescimento lineares de um abismo enorme
entre as pessoas e vamos com paradigma
da abundância aonde a gente sai do medo
e passa colaboração do compartilhamento
para inclusão para diversidade sai do
passado e vamos para um novo futuro né
vamos acabar com esse hierarquia que
insiste tirar o ser humano
e aí
que estabelece as relações de forma
formal né e quando o ser humano entra
nela eles estabelecem novas relações de
poder que tem tudo menos a ver com ser
humano
nós vamos ter uma forma organizacional
que ela não é centralizada ela não é de
centralizado ela não é distribuída mas
ela se configura de acordo com a tarefa
de distribuído ela passa se
descentralizar e passa a centralizar e
eu crio em cima disso um ciclo infinito
que se retro alimenta que permite que
todo o produto que sai dessa produção e
desse empreendimento não é seja
distribuído por quem participa dessa
grande rede vai fazendo isso crescer não
negócio que a singularity university do
rei cold a chama da lei dos retornos
acelerados aonde os crescimentos são
duplamente exponenciais porque elas
remam como é que a vida se comporta é um
negócio que trabalha com duas visões uma
visão da eficiência de fazer certo as
coisas que olha só para sobrevivência
daquela organização para uma visão que
una eficácia eu faço
e as coisas certas né eu junto a
sobrevivência com evolução para gerar
prosperidade e aí nasceu em 2016 um
texto que está na internet ela mandou
organização próspera que a gente
estabeleceu os princípios da organização
próxima partida do modelo de fazer certo
as coisas certas mais uma hierarquia
totalmente horizontal onde não tem
cadeia de comando e controle ou de não
tem chefe não tem comitê não tem grupo
gestor não tem ninguém não tem síndico
não tem centro né numa governança que
não tá trabalhando com uma noção falsa
de democracia que é pelo padre poder do
veto do voto o voto hoje ser serve para
gente criar uma dinâmica de dominação da
minoria por uma maioria
e a democracia pelo voto são dois lobos
e um cordeiro decidir qual é o jantar u
e a gente precisa atender todo mundo
democracia é eu poder atender todos que
participam e aí eu preciso de uma
liderança que não seja identificada de
cima para baixo em nomeada mas sim que
ela é merge de quem quer ser líder
daquela tarefa naquele momento num
orçamento que não é centralizado que
depende de relações políticas para eu
investir num projeto ou numa pessoa ou
num novo negócio mas sinta distribuído
por todos aqueles que usam o seu poder
para dizer eu em visto meu trabalho o
dinheiro que eu tenho alçada em cima
desse projeto tá que ele funciona e aí
eu atendo todo mundo não planejamento
que hoje é usado para aprisionar as
pessoas em resultados pré-estabelecidos
às vezes envolvendo a empresa como um
todo mas na verdade vem de cima para
baixo para sincronizações presentes
aonde todo mundo na organização declara
o que tá fazendo aonde quer chegar e o
que que é necessário
você pode escolher para que lado vai
numa gestão financeira que seja
totalmente transparente aberta que possa
ser editado pela menor parte que é o
indivíduo dentro da sua organização
o nosso usando esse teste 2016 quatro
organizações nasceram uma chamada cripto
transferir que buscava entender o bloco
bem escrito ativos e como usar isso no
dia a dia assim que a gente começou a
entender isso nasceu uma editora que
publique livro chamado botinha evolution
de forma colaborativa primeira
experiência num que todo mundo recebeu
uma participação das vendas desse livro
e recebe até hoje nasceu uma organização
para aquelas pessoas que não conseguem
mais o trabalho formal porque elas são
empregáveis mas tem uma experiência
maluca e hoje são assistentes virtuais
que trabalham para várias empresas às
vezes de casa às vezes da sua cidade
pequena onde não teria nenhuma chance e
conseguem ganhar e se sustentar com
causa disso e nasceu e daí vem essa
minha coisa com comida não não só pelo
fato do meu tamanho
o gui quem quer experimentar a trabalhar
com alimento artesanal e não tem
infraestrutura não tem acesso não tem
receita não tem conhecimento e não pode
pagar uma uma educação formal ou não tem
tempo ou não tem recursos para isso só
que nós percebemos é que o mesmo cara
que transaciona aplicativo que trabalha
com a editora aqui tá prestando
consultoria também cozinhava e não fazer
a sentido quatro organizações lineares
mas sim uma organização única que
reunisse toda essa gente trabalhando e
empreendendo com o ativo digital o
próspero
o que fazia todas essas relações como
moeda como ação como títulos de
fidelidade qualquer coisa que a gente
precisasse e aí em abril de 2017 eu e
meu sócio osvaldo inauguramos e lançamos
a prospera junto com o livro boate
revolution que era o nosso primeiro
modelo infelizmente em 2017 em dezembro
osvaldo nos deixou de forma trágico e eu
tive continuar sozinho tive começar a
olhar para aquelas pessoas que falar
como a gente organiza isso como eu trago
essas pessoas e faça elas entenderem sem
eu precisar pegar na mão de cada uma e
explicar como aquilo funcionava que era
muito desgastante e nós partimos do
princípio existe um bem comum cada uma
dessas organizações e são ativos que a
marca que é o reconhecimento que são os
produtos que eu conhecimentos e esse bem
comum é compartilhado é distribuído para
quem quiser construir qualquer coisa e
assim nasce uma editora e assim nasce
uma organizadora de
e nas em programas educacionais e assim
nascem programas internacionais de
viagem o primeiro ia ser feito agora mas
na vírus resolveu atrapalhar o nosso
desenvolvimento e assim nasce a
consultoria em termos organizações
distribuídas tudo isso auto-organizado
as pessoas podem participar com aquele
talento que elas tenham querem ter se eu
quero aprender o passo aprender
trabalhando eu não preciso mudar de
emprego eu não preciso me formar eu
posso ir lá e liderar um processo pelo
simples processo de aprender a fazer
aquilo e todo mundo vai ajudar todo
mundo vai apoiar todo mundo vai
colaborar e aí na materializam os várias
coisas né a gente faça eventos
gastronômicos e hoje eu me meto a chefe
e mentor cozinhar graças a deus ninguém
teve um troço ainda eventos distribuídos
em bloqueio organizamos 25 eventos em 13
cidades em uma semana primeira botinha
em um mundo que foi caráter nível
nacional geralmente se organizado em uma
cidade nós temos medo de
e agora aqui do livro botinha evolution
vamos lançar o livro sobre organizações
horizontais uma parceria também com o
canadá o programa de imersão no exterior
vai ter que ser online aí e um programa
de especialização que mais de 20 pessoas
participaram da produção então
participando da gestão nesse programa na
cruz era tudo isso trabalhando como
investidores como participantes como
sócios nós não temos empregado todo
mundo é sócio num sistema onde a receita
entra ela é transparente e ela é usada
para pagar as despesas as pessoas que
participam devolve para turma que
construiu o bem comum como forma de
reconhecer aquele trabalho que foi feito
e contribuir para sua manutenção e não
se apropriado o que foi feito por outro
para benefício próprio e até uma parte a
gente devolve para o ecossistema para
que as pessoas continuem vindo e gerem
receitas relacionadas a esse a pro
ó e aqui é onde eu vou falar de bloco em
bloco sem serve para resolver isso não
vou mais falar de cola quente
o site traz um grande bem comum the
block em que criou um selo editorial
editor livre as pessoas que participaram
desse processo quinta-feira agora
inauguraram lançaram o primeiro livro
produzido por uma editora colaborativa o
nosso editor que passou muito mal quando
a gente começou a fazer esse livro
apoiado pela editora do senai saiu do
senai montoro editora dele faria e silva
e tá lançando um livro de não-ficção e
tem quatro linhas de literatura baseada
nessa aprendizado e aí a gente começou
né nós temos um livro nós temos evento
nós temos a educação a educação online
nós temos eventos nacionais e todo esse
monte de coisa e nós percebemos que cada
um desses objetos como a gente chama
gera um novo tipo de organização cujo
bem comum é o conhecimento na execução
daquele processo o bem comum de execução
de
é uma execução de publicações de livros
ou a na educação e outras tantas estão
vendo designers e criativos que ajudam
nesse projeto começaram a falar em uma
organização para produzir criatividade e
a produtos relacionados a intervenções
artísticas na cidade
a polícia eu consegui qual era o meu
objetivo eu consigo ser eu como pessoa
eu consigo ser eu como profissional eu
consigo cumprir o meu propósito quando
eu sou mentor quando eu só jornalista
quando eu sou empresário quando eu sou
professor quando eu sou avatar
e quando eu sou palestrante quando eu
sou ifood porque o ano de escuta né
quando eu sou pirata quando eu viajo e
vou experimentar nas cidades que eu
visito é recomendar algumas coisas que a
gente gosta no meio do caminho quando
organiza eventos com culinária ou quando
eu mesmo vou para cozinha ou quando eu
sou esportista
e quando eu sou pai
e quando o seu marido de uma mulher
maravilhosa que faz algo que eu não
tenho coragem fico cada vez mais
impressionado com esse tipo de coisa
rodrigo me deixou emocionado hoje
e quando são palmeiras ou quando sou
brasil afora o quando eu sou james bond
e o coração tiozão do pavê
a mais na verdade tudo isso é para dizer
que é possível eu sei um nó de uma rede
e na internet tem certeza que vários
deles estão aqui tem uns três ou quatro
por aqui que participam desse grupo mas
uma coisa eu aprendi
olá tudo que o homem semear ele também
colhe e agora eu sei que eu também posso
ser palhaço
e aí